People around the world who are fighting for equality.
And I really mean this.
There are totally annoyed at the New York, Hollywood,
West Hollywood, gays, who,
who raise a lot of money for black tie events.
And aren't doing a thing to help our brothers and sisters in Lebanon who
are getting arrested.
[Inaudible].
I went to the 1993 March on Washington for, uh, when,
when bill Clinton and Al Gore had taken over.
And that March was incredible because there I'm going to get the number wrong
and somebody's gonna come out. Oh yeah,
I think it was like a million people write a male gays and lesbians and straight
supporters all came out to Washington and marched.
And it was dramatic in that. I think it was that, that point,
that, that things became political, um,
on gays and lesbians and the LGBT movement. Um, before then,
we've kind of all were on the outs. And so we were together.
We were in Washington, you know, people, Republicans and Democrats were, uh,
not making this, the wedge issue,
but I will say that the, that the March on Washington,
um, left our community with a sense of, we just want equality.
And if you go back to that, March, Dave,
the mantra was tolerance and diversity.
We recognized that other people were not going to agree with us.
And our whole request,
our ask was just embrace diversity.
We know you don't, you don't agree with everything that, that, you know,
we stand for, but let's just be tolerant of each other. So remember,
hate is not a family value was this whole thing.
Now the entire leadership of the LGBT movement in Washington,
DC is all about cancel culture and absolutely
pushing people out of the argument to say, I'm,
I don't even want to be friends with you. If you voted for Trump or you're gay,
conservative, I can't even fathom being friends with you.
Well, now they also want to take your gayness away, right?
So they'll write articles,
that famous article in our magazine about how Peter teal is not gay enough
because it's because it's not who you have sex with or who you love that makes
you gay. It's actually a political way of thinking that makes you gay, which is.
Which is why glad, um, has this whole like immigration.
And it's a movement beyond anything that has to do with gays and
lesbians. And I think it's an example they're trying to survive, right?
That just the cops need a certain amount of crime type of thing.
It's like we got equal rights and not to say everything is perfect and right.
But I work, I work around the world.
Let me tell you people around the world who are fighting for
equality. And I really mean this.
There are totally annoyed at the New York, Hollywood,
West Hollywood, gays, who,
who raised a lot of money for black tie events.
And aren't doing a thing to help our brothers and sisters in Lebanon who
are getting arrested or look what happened in Zambia.
They literally prosecuted to two guys for being gay. And the court said, Oh no,
we're doing this because they're gay. They didn't make up some pedophilia.
No, no. But if you say something about that, you're somehow racist, right.
Or you're beautiful or something like that because you're pushing your values,
but some values are better than others. That must be the number one thing.
You have to fight all the time, right?
At the UN or over the years at the UN that you had to fight that now as an
ambassador.
I'm now fighting this thing at the state department where,
when it comes to the decriminalization campaign, um, so you're,
you're spearheading this thing, right? I'm spearheading this thing. Uh,
there's 69 countries that criminalize,
homosexuality 10 will kill you for being gay.
And we've launched a process. Uh, we've done a whole bunch.
We're trying to stay out of the media in terms of telling them every little
thing, uh, because the media is pretty hostile to something like this. Uh,
we've, we've, we're making great progress.
He is pretty hostile to something like decriminalize it.
From the Trump administration. Right? Honestly.
Well, we'll get to that.
I was about to tell you a second ago that we've talked for about a half hour or
so. And until about a minute ago, the T word had not come up yet,
which I think is a record. Uh, but we'll, so we'll get to that in a second,
but sorry, go ahead.
But the decriminalization campaign, um,
w we're making so much progress, uh,
granted this is going to be a long fight, uh,
trying to convince 69 countries to do a change in
domestic laws to, to not criminalize homosexuality. And that's all, this is,
is step one is just to work on criminalization.
Others are working on step two through 20.
I felt the need to do step one, because when I look around the world, step one,
wasn't really being pushed. Um, I've been working with, no,
this is going to be bad cause they're probably going to go after them. But, um,
I've been working with Stuart milk of the Harvey milk foundation.
Who's fantastic. Who's totally focused on this problem.
And so what we're trying to do is to have 69 different,
uh, campaigns basically, cause you've got to work with the local, um,
community remarkable stories that I could just go in over and over that I
don't,
because I don't want to highlight it and scare people away that are working in
these countries. But suffice to say, um,
this was a fight that needed to happen. That was not happening.
And right now I have to face at the state department
resistance from people who don't want Americans or Westerners to go into other
countries and take a stand for the decriminalization campaign.
Because literally there are countries that believe that the West and
specifically America have imported into their country being gay.
And so they're like, Oh no,
no American should talk about this because you're going to emphasize my position
back is that's the stupidest idea that Americans brought in the
gay. Right.
Right. There were no gay people before America. It's only about 200 year thing.
Right?
So I'm not going to actually be silent on that and participate in letting them
silence me because they've got some crazy conspiracy theory.
I'm going to bust the conspiracy theory wide open and say, you're wrong.
How do you decide the, when to use extra pressure to get a country,
to do something? Because I know as,
as generally as a conservative and from what I know about you,
you don't love the idea of telling countries what to do.
Like it's not really like in the conservative ethos. Right.
And yet I understand you want people to be free.
So how do you decide when we can apply more pressure or questions? Yeah.
I got one. I get one every interview.
Sure. I would say that I have this philosophy that,
that as a diplomat,
I am working at the state department and I have to be successful
in order to avoid war.
Because if you have diplomats who are not successful,
that file of a problem gets transferred over to the Pentagon and they don't
negotiate. They just solved the problem.
And so I firmly believe that diplomats should be at the forefront
of pushing and prodding and demanding talks and demanding that we have a
table to, to, you know, air our grievances on, even before, like,
if we're planning to bomb, if, if the, if DOD is ready to,
to attack, I would hope that we have brave diplomats that are saying,
wait a minute, I got one more chance. Let's sit down,
let's try the diplomacy thing. So, you know, I get hit constantly for, Oh,
you're undiplomatic or you're too tough. And I thought,
that's what you want in the diplomat.
Cause you want to have somebody that's working hard to avoid war,
to talk through,
through pushing and prodding rather than transferring the file over and,
and, you know, having a problem solved through military act.
Has some of that been tough for you though,
because you used to fight on Twitter more or be more of like a battler there
where, you know, you've, you're an ambassador now you're a guy in a hoodie.
You've calmed it down a little bit.
I still think that I pick my fights. Um,
I don't feel like I've backed off. What I do think is,
um, that, that I want to make sure that someone is in that fight.
And so I look to see, you know, like, uh,
a media bias issue.
I still get really charged up if the group think in
Washington or the political circles is one way.
And nobody's challenging that I'm willing to jump in.
I don't care if I have the title of ambassador,
I'm still gonna jump in and try to push and correct the record where I see fit,
if others are doing it. And thank God you're in there to do it. Uh,
then sometimes I can little ground support.
I can let it go and look for the next problem. Yeah.
Um,
can you talk a little bit about just generally what the state of the UN is and
what it was like to be there and you know,
that so many people think that it's like this sort of perfect thing that the
countries come together and figure out what's right for everybody.
Like they love the idea of it more than I think functionally how it works or
does not work.
Well, first of all, the, uh,
I always try to correct people that the UN doesn't really exist.
The UN is member States, right? So when somebody says, Oh, the UN says, no,
I always say the UN doesn't say no members at the UN,
maybe Russia and China got together in the security council and said, no,
but the UN doesn't take a position. And so I,
I try to not just reflexively blame, Oh,
the UN stopped something cause it's really member countries.
That's the first thing. The second thing is,
is the UN does not work unless the U S is leading it.
Whether it's the world food program, UNICEF UN DP, you know,
the development programs, whatever it is, the us has to be there.
Otherwise the UN does not work.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.